مجموعه خارجه اطار الدوله نظريا لكن بمهام
مختلفه في روسيا والصين
حظيت قوات الامن الصينيه في الخارج
باهتمام كبير في السنوات الاخيره تعمل
شركات الامن هذه المدعومه من الحكومه
الصينيه على الصعيد الدولي وتقدم خدمات
امنيه للاستثمارات الصينيه ومشاريع البنيه
التحتيه والمواطنين في الخارج تتالف من
افراد المدربين من ذوي الخلفيه العسكريه
غالبا ما تتشكل من المتقاعدين من الجنود
او ضباط انفاذ القانون تتخصص شركات الامن
هذه في حمايه مشاريع البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه تاتي الاهميه الحاسمه للمصالح
الاقتصاديه للصين
شركه الصينيه تعمل مجموعه فاغنرك شركه
عسكريه خاصه تحت مظله الحكومه الروسيه وهي
معروفه بتقديم الخبره العسكريه وخدمات
الافراد بمقابل مادي غالبا في مناطق عدم
الاستقرار السياسي واجهت انتقادات بسبب
طبيعتها المرتزقه اذ يجادل البعض بانها
تعمل بشكل مستقل عن الحكومه الروسيه بينما
يزعم انها تحافظ على علاقات وثيقه معها
بينما تلعب كل من قوات الامن الصينيه في
الخارج ومجموعه باجنر الروسيه ادوارا مهمه
في المشهد الامني العالمي هناك اختلافات
واضحه في نهجها وعملياتها في الحاله
الصينيه تفرض على هذه الشركات قوانين
صارمه من الحزب الشيوعي تحدد حتى نوعيه
التسليح وتبقيه في اطار الاسلحه الخفيفه
لضمان عدم تضخم هذه الشركات وتخطها للحدود
المرسومه لها لكن في الحاله الروسيه
خاصا مدفوعا بالربح وترتبط بعقودا مع طالب
الخدمه لكن تنوع تسليحها والاستعانه بها
في مهام ضخمه اوصل الامر هناك للمشهد الذي
سيبقى في التاريخ زحف ارتال فاجنر نحو
موسكو الى عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات